[Music]
today we're gonna be giving spam
stranger things inspired looks and I
will be dressing the characters today so
the show is set in late 70s early 80s
mid western America a lot of the clothes
that they wear are so wearable even in
this day and age because vintage
recycles itself and I think one of the
most remarkable things about the
characters on the show is how they all
seem to have their own distinct personal
style each character really has their
individual looks that brings their
personality to life so this isn't just
your typical recreation it's not meant
to be cost to me it's supposed to be
really wearable like say if barb is a
girl you're hanging out with in
Williamsburg at a dive bar what she'd be
wearing in the modern day so for will
there's that really amazing opening
scene where he's seen riding his bike
disappearing into the upside down so one
of the looks that we wanted to do for
him was the one with the puffer
two-toned jacket and then we have this
plaid flannel underneath and it also has
those red tones in the chevron on the
jacket so it's a nice color play and I
think it works well together I'm a big
fan of stranger things I do feel like a
slightly older version of will you know
he liked the clash a lot and they were
pretty ritzy when it came to their
jackets so I think it's pretty sweet
I actually related to will a lot I was
always pretty awkward in middle school I
was kind of a smaller scrawny kid people
tended to pick on me from time to time I
also moved around a lot so I was more
like lost than I think most kids were my
mom and I were kind of just like the
only ones for a while she was a single
mom for most of my childhood life so
really related to him a lot on that 11
is a central character in the show and
one of her most liked clonic looks is
that pink dress with the blue jacket
it's a really important part of the
series just because that's the first
time she gets to go out and go to school
with the kids and interact with everyone
we gave her a corduroy jumper paired
with this a really cute navy bomber and
some white sneakers it's kind of like a
sporty tomboy vibe and I really think it
speaks to her character because she's
really tough and she's basically up for
anything this outfit is actually really
cool this jacket is kind of oversized
which is really nice I'm pretty sure 11
would totally be rocking this outfit
right now if she were walking down the
streets 11 is one of my favorite
characters on the show
she is such a badass does things without
even having to tap into her powers she
just does it out of the necessity of
making sure her friends are okay and I
think that's the coolest thing in the
world
Justin has kind of like a quirky or
personal style I think then they're all
the other characters he's always wearing
those trucker hats and his signature
graphic tees we kind of did a little
twist on this instead of his brown
colored khakis we paired with a skirt
and kind of turned around so that a girl
or a woman can also wear like a dustin
inspired outfit I put her in a denim
jacket instead of his puffy oversized
coat just to update it a little bit and
keep it modern so I'm in the girl
version of the look I think that it's
still definitely something that I could
wear out I'm really digging this jean
jacket I want to keep it I'm not kidding
the best thing about Dustin is he's like
in it for the friends he's in it for the
team and I think that I'm also in it for
my friends new team so we have that kind
of parallel going where you just want to
make sure like everybody's good and like
fighting for a good cause for Lucas we
chose to recreate the look where he's
wearing that bandanna I feel like that's
kind of like his leg war paint with such
an iconic look for him he's always
wearing these great shearling jacket so
I think that's kind of his signature
look and Lucas is gonna be wearing
skinny jeans today just to update the
look a little bit to tie it all together
Lucas this fashion I feel is very smart
but also outdoorsy it's back in style
but the character of Lucas I actually
relate to the most am the friend that's
always the voice of reason but still
continues to go with the band of friends
but always in the back of my mind I'm
always questioning why are we doing this
and what's going to be the end for barb
her signature look is definitely the
oversized spectacles paired with a plaid
shirt possibly as ruffles or some kind
of embellishment but in kind of like a
quirky way we updated her look with
floral blouse and
Levi's and a little French bag to give
it a little bit of an edge and I think
that her overall look is just very
wearable because it's really casual it's
basically just like jeans and a blouse
you can just do so much with that
there's like that main picture that
everyone has of her where it's like very
diary in the pants area and this is like
it come down which is good cause you
know we don't want diapers I think I
really like barb because she's like
really didn't go [ __ ] just nice because
it's night you see all these people like
following around with peer pressure and
she's kind of like I don't wanna do that
and I'm just gonna do my own thing but
then she didn't buy a monster so that's
unfortunate I hope you guys like the
looks it was really fun creating all of
these characters and if you're inspired
by this video to go out and create your
own looks dive into your first store
grab some friends grab some lights and
just make it a party